Her last breath slowly fills up her lungs
Feet float to the top of the toy chest
Red scarf unwinds itself from her neck
The Korean pop song unplays on a loop. Tears crawl back up their paths into her eyes
Sadness unfolds itself to blinding anger
The paper's blotchy letters come into focus
The idea leaves her head
Doors unslam. Words claw back into her mouth settling in the fire of her gut
She's having her last fight with me
But I don't know that yet
"I hate you"
Slams back into my mouth
The pink homemade Valentine's card she knocked over leaps from the floor and into place on my desk
She paces backwards swallowing the vomit of no one understands.
No one knows, No one listens, No one cares, No one loves me
I'm Alone
She un-opens my door
I have a sister still.